[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de présidentielle 360
voici les titres françois hollande sort
du silence pour lui cette campagne sont
mauvais il s'exprime dans la presse et
s'en prend à la mode mélenchon très
sévère avec le candidat socialiste
benoît hamon il n'appelle pas pour
autant à voter emmanuel macron analyses
et décryptages dans un instant la
campagne vu du terrain suite de notre
série ce soir nous avons suivi nicolas
dupont aignan à paris et jean lassalle
en seine-saint-denis en banlieue où vous
allez les voir l'accueil a plutôt été
chaleureux pour le béarnais reportage à
suivre les propositions de la haute
autorité pour plus de transparence dans
la vie publique et le réclament un
meilleur encadrement les indemnité
représentative de frais de mandat qui
ont pu le servir à l'enrichissement
personnel de certains élus
le détail dans cette édition et je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez réagir à cette
émission sur les réseaux sociaux via
twitter hashtag présidentielle 360
changement de stratégie pour françois
hollande face à la percée spectaculaire
de jean-luc mélenchon
le président de la république a choisi
de s'exprimer à douze jours du premier
tour
pas de consignes de vote officiel mais
dans un entretien au point et au site
internet combiné il livre sa vision de
la situation politique quand un calme et
en sortant du silence françois hollande
se montre très incisif d'abord envers le
niveau du débat cette élection
présidentielle dans l'hebdomadaire le
point à paraître demain le président de
la république juge la campagne hors sol
est centrée sur les affaires autre cible
jean luc mélenchon visés par cette
phrase il y à un péril face aux
simplifications face aux falsifications
qui fait que l'on regarde le spectacle
du tribun plutôt que le contenu de son
texte une interview au point à paraître
demain ou françois hollande plaide pour
le renouvellement politique
autre sortie médiatique le président
république a accordé une interview aux
médias en ligne combinée
un site dédié aux jeunes est très
présent sur les réseaux sociaux
dans les extraits disponibles sur
l'application snapshot le président
république est interrogé sur ses
conseils et aux électeurs de 2012 et qui
sont plutôt temps une référence cryptée
au mouvement en marche et qui pourrait
signer une rupture dans la communication
du président république et stéphane le
foll le porte parole du gouvernement
s'en est également pris au programme de
jean luc mélenchon je vous propose tout
de suite de l'écouter voyez ce matin un
porte parole de jean luc mélenchon qui
qui disaient qu'ils avaient d aider
c'était sur le fond que les gens à
adhérer mais sur le fond c'est quoi
je crois que c'est 270 milliards de
dépenses publiques supplémentaires avec
des conséquences sur les impôts c'est
bien sûr hors cadre européen donc on est
bien dans l'hypothèse d'un plan b un cas
évoqué jean luc mélenchon cirque en kit
l'europe et on quitte la zone euro mais
les conséquences sont les mêmes pour les
gens modestes tout ça s'apaise et je les
dis aussi ça je le rajoute donc des bacs
qui a eu lieu ce matin c'est que les
pays du sud qui commence à sortir des
difficultés voient le risque de remise
en cause de la zone euro et de l'europe
comme une menace
donc c'est les plus fragiles qui seront
les plus touchés et dans cette campagne
plombé par les affaires c'est un rapport
qui risque d'être scrutés à la loupe
celui de la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique dans le
collimateur le patrimoine et les
indemnités des parlementaires
explication c'est sexo beaucoup reste à
faire en matière de transparence
voilà le premier bilan de la haute
autorité si désormais les élus sont plus
nombreux à devoir déclarer leur
patrimoine
quinze mille huit cents contre 10000 en
2014 l'accès à ces déclarations restent
encore trop
compliqué car aujourd'hui pour les
consulter il faut prendre rendez-vous en
préfecture et il est interdit de les
divulguer la haute autorité préconise
donc de les publier sur son site
internet
elle recommande aussi de l'étendre à
celle des conjoints
l'autre domaine sur lequel l'organisme
souhaite plus de transparence ce sont
les indemnités de frais de mandat le
fameux yes fm un gros chèque de près de
6000 euros non imposables verser tous
les mois aux parlementaires en plus du
salaire et de l'envelope alloués pour
les assistants parlementaires
elle est censée couvrir les frais de
repas de déplacement et de loyer des
permanences
mais certains élus sont sauvés servi
pour s'enrichir personnellement
en investissant dans des biens
immobiliers ou en les plaçant sur des
comptes privés
certains seraient même parti en vacances
grâce à cet argent
la haute autorité préconise donc de
mieux l'encadrer car aujourd'hui une
simple déclaration sur l'honneur suffit
super présent de notre série consacrée à
la campagne sur le terrain le candidat
de debout la france nicolas dupont
aignan espère bien l'attirer déçus de
françois fillon à l'écouté des gens et
les le seul d'ailleurs avoir répondu à
l'appel d'un collectif d'handicapés qui
a souhaité interpeller les candidats à
la présidentielle jean bonard ces
courageux son parti de nantes le 25 mars
dernier pour faire la marche d oublier
un périple de 450 kilomètres objectif
interpeller les candidats de la
présidentielle
une initiative menée par les handicapés
de france celui qui s'estiment souvent
aussi comme un oublié de cette campagne
était le seul candidat venu les
accueillir ce mardi pas sur les
personnes handicapées en attendant
dutroux parle exactement sur les débats
j'avais derrière ça a bougé parce qu'on
aime
aujourd'hui il a des oublis j'ai pas
cette prétention
ça serait prétentieux mais ce serait pas
bien de dire ça les personnes en
situation de handicap sont vraiment pour
le co2 les oubliés de la société
je me dis qu'on peut redistribuer
différemment l'argent public j'en suis
convaincu nicolas dupont aignan est
aussi convaincu qu'il peut encore
séduire plaisir en légère hausse dans
les sondages ils peinent cependant à
dépasser les 4%
mais peu importe j'ai par exemple dans
le dernier sondage 18% de potentiel
électoral de gens qui disent qu'ils
peuvent voter pour moi autant que
monsieur fillon il monsieur hamon
quasiment la campagne elle commence tout
juste
et c'est pourquoi elle commence tout
juste parce que ça fait simplement deux
jours quelle égalité de temps de parole
alors pour mettre toutes les chances de
son côté nicolas dupont aignan multiplie
les rencontres et les poignées de main
bonjour mes yeux cette fois opération
séduction chez les commerçants ce
buraliste par exemple se questionne sur
le rsi le régime social des indépendants
que le candidat veut supprimer sept ans
vous avez repris ce mardi
j'aurais il se bat et là l'air mais si
je pleurais une demande de remboursement
ce parce que le temps buralistes je paye
de cotisations sur les allées jusqu'à
aujourd'hui j'ai jamais aimé personne ne
comprendra jamais rien ce week-end je
n'ai jamais rien compris chaque ministre
invente des statuts différents
et puis on a un bazar incroyable est
d'ailleurs plus personne n'y comprend
rien je mets au défi un mini jeu
l'économie du savoir tous les statuts
qui existent donc mon idée un statut
unique les indépendants nicolas dupont
aignan réussira-t-il à convaincre
il dit les choses après un projet pas
encore le candidat de debout la france à
lui déjà décider de ce qu'il fera au
second tour vous ferez contre les deux
tours mais je ferai campagne
pour qui pour le second tour pour moi
m'aurait pas en 2012 il avait obtenu 1
79% des voix au premier tour
gros plan à présent sur la campagne de
jean lassalle les lieux du sud ouest
étaient à saint denis en banlieue
parisienne
fort de son franc parler de son accent
des pyrénées il est allé à la rencontre
des habitants ravis d'accueillir un
candidat à la présidentielle dans ces
territoires un peu oubliés de la
campagne fabien becker oui c'est un
berger en campagne dans la banlieue
parisienne
bonjour et c'est là jean lassalle 61 ans
le candidat de la ruralité
visiblement aussi à l'aise dans le 93
que dans son béarn natal avant son mot
d'ordre
tel un mantra apaisé et rassembler une
france qui souffre ce matin à
saint-denis une mosaïque de cultures et
de religions
le candidat veut incarner ce
rassemblement tournée de celle fille et
accolades à la sortie de la messe un
style pour le moins originale qui
provoque la curiosité et l'amusement et
si tous les habitants ne le
reconnaissent pas certains sont
carrément séduit
mais j'ai regardé jusqu'au bout et vous
est celui qui m'a le plus âgé on définit
taupier moi je mate avec mon coeur donc
j'ai fait de la création de ce réseau
c'est simon l utopie aussi de chez moi
on va transformer des tories en réalité
ce que vous dites dans votre lit et
j'espère tourner la retire de ce monde
des séries le candidat une mesure phare
un service civique et militaire de neuf
mois pour réconcilier la jeunesse du
pays
c'est ma mesure la plus chère 12
milliards mais il ne peut pas y avoir de
grade retrouvailles et de réunions de ce
grand pays qu'est le raid et le gign est
ce la france silencieuse
la france est triste la france ça merde
la rada joyeuse une france joyeuse à
laquelle veulent croire une poignée de
militants les personnes ont un moment
d'hésitation parce que recevoir des
tracts je pense qu'ils en reçoivent
beaucoup et un sourire dès qu'ils voient
que c'est jean lassalle et il est
finalement connu il sait ce que c'est de
délaisser parce que les ruralité faut
voir ce qu'ils sont en france qui sont
aussi livrés à eux-mêmes délaissés et
parfois même oublié un peu comme les
banlieues
moi je suis convaincu convaincu comme
jean lassalle lui même à 2 % dans les
sondages
l'élu du béarn a réaffirmé sa certitude
de devenir président de la république
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre françois
hollande sort de sa réserve inquiet de
la montée de jean luc mélenchon alors
comment interpréter ces prises de
positions mais deux invités m'ont
rejoint sur ce plateau pour en parler
j'ai plaisir d'accueillir louis lepron
bonsoir vous êtes rédacteur en chef du
site combiné qui va et bien diffusé la
semaine prochaine une interview de
françois hollande on va bien sûr en
parler dans un instant et tristan kino
maupoil bonsoir vous êtes journaliste
politique au figaro
première question pour vous au louis
lepron quel message le chef de l'état
vous êtes si le délivrer et comment
perçoit-il cette campagne il a été
justement assez succinct au niveau de la
nouvelle campagne on a essayé justement
d'instaurer une discussion entre les
actions combinées et donc françois
hollande et pas forcément de
prédisposition à parler de politique on
voulait surtout avoir une discussion
autour de lui de sa présidence et de son
après présidence il a juste dit
justement enfin encore une fois qu'il
n'avait pas de commentaire de candidats
l'expérience elle qui voulait soutenir
en particulier y avait juste quelques
indications mais c'était évidemment
toujours un peu flou ouais il parle
quand même ce qu'on a pu voir des
extraits d'une marche vers le progrès
c'est un soutien du bout des lèvres
emmanuel macron interpréter chacun y
voit et chacun il fait souvent de très
près enfin une interprétation
personnelle a vacillé vous la connaissez
chacun a droit de voir un peu ce qui ce
qu'ils veulent dans quoi tristan qui
nouveaux poils c'est un changement de
pierre pour françois hollande qui sort
de sa réserve en ce qu'il ne voulait pas
intervenir avant le second tour
et ce n'est pas que la montée du front
national qui l'inquiète c'est cette fois
la percée de jean luc mélenchon comment
l'expliquez vous oui et puis une autre
chose aussi il cherche la réhabilitation
de son propre mandat ça c'est quand même
il était inquiet par jean luc mélenchon
il n'y a pas une mais c'est surtout
vis-à-vis de son prisme à lui parce que
l'élection de jean luc mélenchon ça
occulterait totalement son mandat
l'élection de marine le pen
ça serait impossible de là encore de
réhabiliter son mandat il ya une chance
c'est emmanuel macron il pourrait dire
qu'il a été un passeur de relais entre
deux générations
et puis ce serait aussi une forme de
validation de sa politique économique
donc quand il parle à combiner de
renouvellement de progrès et c'est alors
il dit j'ai 2 et métiers pour pas que
pour entretenir encore un faux suspense
entre benoît hamon dit y en a plusieurs
il en a plusieurs
on imagine que ça peut se jouer entre
deux la réalité en fait c'est qu'elle
n'a qu'un seul c'est emmanuel macron et
puisque benoît hamon a en tout le
quinquennat dans une bonne partie du
quinquennat a été un frondeur et a coulé
françois hollande donc c'est emmanuel
macron réellement son candidat est et
veut sa planche de salut pour sauver son
l'image de son quinquennat
ouais c'est ce que vous avez ressenti
également louis lepron dans le message
que vous a délivré le chef de l'état bah
c'était bien mais pas forcément dans
vies particulières en tout cas quand il
a voulu quand il a voulu avec quand il
accepte en tout cas de venir à combiner
pas forcément je pense une volonté de
communication peut-être oui et être un
lien par rapport aux promesses qu'il
avait faites en 2012 par rapport à la
jeunesse qui était sa priorité donc
peut-être à sa fin de mandat doit
revenir dans une dans une entreprise qui
est dans un média qui aussi jeune que le
nôtre c'était peut-être de revenir et de
voir un petit peu la température par
rapport à ce qu'ils avaient fait ses
promesses est ce que est ce qu elles
étaient tenues ou pas mais il n'y avait
pas de message particulier en tout cas
quand nous on l'a eue parce que c'est
vraiment une discussion il ya eu oui
mais ce qui lance un appel à la
mobilisation des jeunes de 18 24 ans qui
pourrait justement ne pas se rendre aux
messages non le message qu il y brille
surtout c'était qu'il fallait surtout
faire attention justement et faire la
part des choses au niveau des médias et
savoir trier l'information
c'était donc ça c'était les réponses par
rapport à des questions qui n'avait pas
enfin que l'elysée avait des dons qu'il
y avait toute autorité justement à dire
bah qu'il fallait juste se renseigner
avant tout pour l'élection sans encore
une fois même s'il a quelques indices
bas sans donner une prédisposition pour
tel ou tel candidat
est-ce que ce qui est très intéressant
effectivement en 2012 françois hollande
s'est présenté comme le candidat de la
jeunesse
et quel désaveu cinq années plus tard on
voit les enquêtes d'opinion sur les
primo votants donc c'est les 18 24 ans
ou qui vont voter pour la première fois
à l'élection présidentielle il y a
quelques mois c'était marine le pen qui
était largement en tête dans les
enquêtes d'opinion chez ces jeunes là à
les rattraper un peu par emmanuel macron
donc là encore il ya une chance pour lui
de dire mais finalement vous voyez les
jeunes
à la fin de mon quinquennat le vaucluse
ont voté pour un modèle macro est nommé
ministre
mais si jamais les jeunes ils votaient
finalement pour marine le pen
là ça serait un désaveu 2012 le candidat
des jeunes 2017
marine le pen la candidate des jeunes
pas prendre ce rappel le site
d'élections régionales et de
l'ajustement du des 35% des des jeunes
dans des 18-30 ans qui avait voté pour
marine le pen
après il faut aussi faire attention aux
sondages parce qu'il a un qui va mettre
nous-mêmes elle ma croix en premier un
autre qui était mélenchon ce matin
encore et un autre qui mettait marine le
pen donc à chaque fois on peut faire
dire ce qu'on veut aux sondages et je
pense que ben on l'attendra je pense le
premier tour et la fin du premier tour
pour savoir vraiment pour qui les jeunes
ont voté très sain qui nous vaut poil il
ya aussi des interviews extraits
diffusés sur combine il ya aussi
l'entretien au point pas un mot sur
benoît hamon est ce qu il a fait une
croix sur le candidat ps c'est celui qui
a coulé son mandat on a beaucoup parlé
de la trahison de daemen macron à qu'il
va planter un couteau dans le dos c'est
vrai mais réellement c'est surtout
benoît hamon et les autres frondeurs qui
l'ont harcelée chaque mois sur chaque
loi sur chaque texte à l'assemblée
nationale
et donc il peut pas le soutenir c'est
impossible
d'ailleurs benoît hamon a dit le sous
entend que c'est françois hollande qui
organise la la la la fuite des soutiens
socialistes verts verts vers macron par
par vengeance on va dire donc non c'est
pas son candidat
il ne le dit pas clairement parce qu'il
veut pas créer crise peut pas être à
l'origine de l'éclatement de sa famille
politique mais mais ça que quand la
question justement par rapport au ps et
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent y un
sympathisant du ps de lui demander un
conseil par rapport au premier tour même
au deuxième tour il a l'air un peu de
gens en mode de bombay rang fait moi
j'ai travaillé quand en premier
secrétaire du ps pendant x années
j'étais présidence à la fin de mon
mandat donc en gros débrouillez-vous
quoi je laisse le passage de relais à
qui veulent prendre même si évidemment
encore une fois il ya un petit indice
qui qui qui indique justement que
maillol accroc pour être soutenu par par
par françois hollande mais je pense qu
il le dira pas parce que justement il
aimerait ne pas peut-être le
le lin disposer d'une certaine manière
on parle du baiser de la mort faut pas
le dire clairement d'ailleurs la droite
l'attaqué depuis maintenant dix jours de
semaine avec le surnom emmanuel emmanuel
hollande
on voit bien que le but de ce surnom
donc françois on ne peut pas trop
s'avancer mais peut glisser quelques
messages
on parlait de jean luc mélenchon qui
visiblement inquiète à françois hollande
comment vous l'expliquez vous à lui le
prix bas c'est quelqu'un qui est en
dehors du parti socialiste qui est je
pense avec son programme qui est assez
loin des des priorités programmatique
par mme danielle manuel da cruz même
d'un benoît hamon enfin même si elle
inclut un champ événements sont souvent
considérés comme ayant un programme
assez similaire mais c'est juste c'est
juste un conseil de sa part après je
sais pas s'il ya vraiment forcément qui
veut mettre forcément l'avant un danger
mais bon c'est son interview dans les
sondages le candidat de la france un
sommier inquiétez pas vouloir enfoncer
le capitaine de pédalo en 2012
cette expression assez ravageuse dont se
souvient encore jean luc mélenchon n'a
jamais été tendre avec avec françois
hollande est là encore si jamais c'est
jean luc mélenchon qui venait à gagner
cette élection présidentielle ça serait
un désaveu pour françois on ne serait
pas là en hommage à sa politique un
moins d'un an on parlait des des 18 24
ans et de la mobilisation peut être que
souhaite françois hollande au ces jeunes
électeurs est-ce qu'il a également fait
le bilan de ces mesures en faveur de la
jeunesse lors de votre entretien il n'y
a pas eu de bilan mais encore une fois
je pense que c'était surtout continuez à
vous renseigner sur les programmes moi
même si les messages évidemment dans le
point et au monde par rapport à la halle
à comment dire à son message par rapport
à jean luc mélenchon et fat qui pouvait
devenir un danger mais il n'a pas faim
il a pas eu de leçons à donner en tous
cas si mal à vraiment c'était un message
assez ses rangs dans le cadre d'une
discussion c'était lui qui nous parlait
donc de sa présidence des coups qu'il a
pu avoir tout en mettant en avant le
fait qu'il lui aussi a pu remporter à
d'autres candidats à une époque
par exemple quel coût il va pas il n'a
pas précisé mais c'était juste une
phrase en mode bombay je savais que
j'allais recevoir mais je sais aussi que
j'ai pu en donner donc je ne suis pas
étonnée d'avoir une présidence aussi du
racing voilà au fond ça on imagine
françois hollande c'est de faire la
passation de pouvoir avec le nomma
marine le pen extrait est soulagé de
voir emmanuel macron ça redonnerait
peut-être un peu de lumière
il est obsédé par la trace qui peut
laisser dans l'histoire politique 7/5
républicain il le dit souvent
et d'ailleurs il compte beaucoup sur le
temps long il sait que les chaînes
d'information continue ça a détruit un
peu son quinquennat ça n'a pas aidé loin
de là mais ils pensent que à la lumière
du temps que c'est son bilan sera sera
revue sera revisitée
mais imaginez marine le pen élue non
voilà ça serait toute une discréditer
son bilan serait complètement
s'arrêterait à ça finalement
cette poignée de main le second mais
voilà qui n'en veut pas ils disent
qu'ils répètent c'est justement son
argument en tout cas s à sa rhétorique
c'est de dire je n'ai je ne suis pas
vraiment détesté en france
il continue ensuite que justement il est
avant tout mal compris en cause sa
politique a été peut-être mal
communiquer ou mal interprétées par les
personnes qui l'ont enfin une somme tant
les médias finalement quillan qui ont pu
il analysé merci leproux l'interview du
chef de l'état c'est donc ce sera donc
en ligne à partir il est déjà en ligne
en fait les des gens ils étaient ce mode
en ligne sur snapshot elle est désormais
en ligne sur le site bien merci d'être
venu en parler ce soir sur ce plateau
merci à vous attestant qu'ils nomment un
point on va continuer et bien nos
émissions spéciales présidentielle 2017
avec michel grossiord qui nous rejoint
tout de suite sur ce plateau bonsoir
michel bonjour vous invité ce soir dans
l'épreuve de vérité
et oui durant cette campagne officielle
donc tous les candidats a logé à la même
enseigne
donc nous recevons balades et des petits
le plus petit d'ailleurs selon les
sondages c'est monsieur jacques
cheminade qui se présente cette année
pour la troisième fois il estime que
nous vivons sous occupation financière
et puis un deuxième
invité ce soir un proche de benoît hamon
en tous les cas son conseiller pour les
dossiers européens et c'est l'économiste
thomas piketty qui est mondialement
connue avec le succès de son livre le
capital au 21ème siècle alors on lui
demandera comment ils jugent la
situation si précaire de son candidat
aujourd'hui benoît hamon qui baissent
encore dans les dernières intentions de
vote on en parlera également dans
l'émission tout à leur merci michel
épreuve de vérité c'est donc à suivre en
direct à partir de 18h30 à présent on va
décrypter le programme d'un autre
candidat à la présidentielle celui de
françois asselineau
[Musique]
et j'accueille tout de suite tu en seras
nuit n'y bonsoir tam alors avec vous
s'il va parler de la principale mesure
du programme de françois asselineau et
concerne le fch exit c'est synonyme pour
lui de nombreuses économies avant d'en
parler avec vous on voit tout de suite
ce qu'il en disait avant-hier lors de
son meeting à lille ça veut dire 34
milliards d'euros d'économies par an 170
milliards sur un quinquennat et
j'insiste sur le fait que ces sommes
considérables vont pouvoir être
récupérée sans qu'on s'attaque au niveau
de vie les français provient d'un tendre
thème françois asselineau estime donc
les économiser les économies réalisées
grâce aux frais xydas 34 milliards
d'euros d'où vient-elle
alors je parle exactement de son
programme dans son programme il parle
d'abord de 20 milliards d'euros qui sont
récupérés sur l'évasion fiscale en
rétablissant le contrôle des mouvements
des capitaux interdit par les traités de
l'union européenne
ensuite il ya 1 5 milliard d'euros qui
sont liées au cofinancement européen et
condamnations pécuniaires et enfin 1 9
milliard d'euros récupérés sur
l'agriculture françois ce nom rappelle
d'ailleurs que la france contribue plus
au budget de l'union européenne qu'elle
ne reçoit elle donne chaque année 23
milliards d'euros et elles ne voient se
voir restituer que 14 milliards dont les
subventions de la pac
ces économies sont elles plausible tant
est bien la surprise c'est que c'est
plutôt plausible je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui l évasion fiscale
elle est estimée à environ 60 à 80
milliards d'euros donc on peut imaginer
qu'en rétablissant le contrôle des
mouvements de capitaux puissant
récupérer un vin et les autres chiffres
également sont plausibles mais françois
asselineau estime aussi que le retour au
franc et la dépréciation qui
s'ensuivraient n'accéderaient pas 10% ce
qui permettrait de relancer l'économie
de baisser ensuite le nombre de chômeurs
de catégorie 1 de 1 à 2 millions en deux
ans qu'en disent les experts
viala ils ne sont pas tous d'accord
entre eux mais ils ne sont pas du tout
d'accord avec françois asselineau
prenez par exemple l'institut montaigne
qui a planché sur le frais xiti il
prévoit lui une dévaluation du franc de
15%
ensuite ils estiment qu'il va y avoir
une envolée des taux d'intérêt
il va ensuite avoir la très forte
augmentation de la dette publique est
finalement un recul de 2,3 à 3 2% du
pipe la première année une chute même de
4 à 13 % sur le long terme
et puis on peut aussi imaginer que il y
aura une tempête sur les marchés
financiers qu'est ce qui va arriver si
la montagne de la dette française est
converti en france en même que les
créanciers soient d'accord
notez également par exemple ce qu'en dit
le gouverneur de la banque de france 1
françois villeroy de galhau lui il
averti sur un surcoût de 30 milliards
d'euros par an sur la dette publique
on est donc loin très loin des 34
milliards d'économies dont pas le
françois asselineau
on peut penser aussi que la zone euro ne
résisterait pas infecté et ré
effectivement un freak site siv est
beaucoup plus grave que le brésil
le royaume uni n'est ni dans la zone
euro ni dans shine gainey dans le pacte
de stabilité et en plus on peut dire
encore qu'aujourd'hui le président n'a
juste pas du tout commençait donc on
n'en connaît pas les conséquences et si
la france est bien revenu et offrant de
nombreux économistes pensent que la zone
euro voire l'union européenne
imploserait de façon non voulues par les
autres membres et donc de façon non
coordonnées que chacun pourrait
peut-être revenir à sa propre monnaie
d'avant l'euro imaginez le franc se
dévaluerait alors par rapport aux
marques mais restera au dessus de la
lyre du tu as bref c'est l'inconnu
total est probablement le chaos
en résumé et bien françois asselineau
n'a pas tort quand il parle des
économies réalisées grâce aux frais exit
mais oublie tout le reste de mentionner
à la tempête qui s'en suivrait la crise
économique et politique majeure qui
frapperait la france et l'union
européenne
merci beaucoup tam merci à vous c'est la
fin de cette édition merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite c'est
l'épreuve de vérité et spéciale élection
présidentielle 2017
invité ce soir jacques cheminade
candidat à cette élection et thomas
piketty économiste qui soutient benoît
hamon bonne soirée et à demain 18h
[Musique]
m